I was looking up other interesting
things about you and oh yeah look out
does that strike Terror into your heart
because when people do it to me I go oh
boy this is about this is where the
interview takes a turn right when
somebody says that don't you think it
does win it's Rob Lowe to be quite
honest I mean the fact that you you know
because you're you're so you're such a
huge celebrity and for you to be like
I've learned this about you it's it is
mind it's mind-blowing
no you're just you're just buttering me
up so that's not true
um your first crush was the guitarist
slash that was your first crush I would
say my first actual Crush as a kid was
probably Jordan Knight from New Kids on
the Block that makes more sense slash is
sort of the he was my sexual Awakening
he's the one who like I I saw him in
that November Rain video and I just
remember thinking why is my body
responding this way yes and so you know
Jordan Knight was my first crush slash
was something
deeper than that because it was we're
not that different in age maybe when I'm
older I can actually be with Slash and
it's not like because my brother had you
know posters of girls in his room he had
you know uh like a lot of guys and I
think it's different for them it's it's
more lust it's more like ah she's hot I
want a picture of her in my room for me
it was one day I think I can be with
Slash one day I think he and I will be
together it's aspirational it's
aspirational and I think it's also you
know we I I you know you write your name
with their last name on your binder you
know you think about long-term plans
it's not just oh I want to you know get
with him it's I want to have a long
meaningful relationship yeah at least
that's how it was for me and I love that
you know I had the rock up on my wall
too because I got into wrestling for a
little while oh so you're you're an
early adapter to the Rock I was oh I was
you know back in the you know WWE days I
used to stay home on Thursday nights
just so I could watch the Thursday night
SmackDown and because I loved the rock
so much but it you know I I wasn't I
never objectified the men I had crushes
on I
wanted to marry them and have their
children and be in a relationship with
them which I think is is sweet and it's
very sweet I think I would like to
imagine what your marriage would be like
to slash
uh I think it would be a disaster
because I think that I would Revere him
so much and I would you know just
I I don't think I could ever beat myself
around him could you get him to stop
wearing the hats absolutely not I would
never that's who he is right between how
dare you even
play could change him and as I'm wearing
a hat by the way I'm wearing a horrible
hat